Mike pillow or just pillow whose real  name is Mike Lindell the founder and CEO  of MyPillow is officially challenging  Republican National Committee chairwoman  Ronna McDaniel for the chairpersonship I  believe we should encourage Michael  Lindell to do this I think it would be  an absolute lovely thing if Mike Lindell  became the chairman of the Republican  Party he is overtly pro-trump Maga he  seems like he would be one of the worst  possible things for the Republican party  that is already trying to sort of fight  off Trump continuing to control the  party I love the idea I'm not going to  donate to the guy I don't even know if  you can donate to RNC chair not going to  donate but I think it would be a great  destruction of the Republican party for  pillow to become its chairman